Speaker 1: We're going to start today with
this continued fiasco involving the January
six Trump riot commission, it is absolutely
stunning what is going on and what has happened
over the last 24 hours, although not altogether
surprising if you've been following the Republican
Party for the last several years.
So yesterday, I told you on the show that
House Minority Leader Republican Kevin McCarthy
had selected five Republicans to be on the
new version of the January 6th commission,
which will investigate what the hell happened
on January 6th.
Now, remember, this commission is instead
of the one that was proposed originally months
ago, which Republicans said absolutely no
to.
And as I pointed out yesterday, at least two
of the five people selected by Kevin McCarthy,
Congressman Jim Jordan and Congressman Jim
Banks are effectively insurrectionists.
Now, what I mean by that is they weren't saying
go to the Capitol right now on January 6th,
but they were participants in the ginning
up of doubt about the election results in
the months leading up to January 6th, which
had people so fired up and almost like in
a feverish state of arousal, where they just
went to the Capitol and did the riots and
attempted the insurrection on January six.
So effectively, you were going to have insiders
investigating the insurrection that they incited.
Now, good for her.
Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi decided
to bar Jim Jordan and Jim Banks from being
on the commission and considering that the
only reason that Jim Jordan and Jim Banks
were going to be there would be to derail
the investigation, to distract from the substance
and to talk about other things like the George
Floyd protests of a year before or whatever
the case may be.
I think it's great that Nancy Pelosi did this.
Now, I know there are people who are going
to say, well, Nancy Pelosi is terrible.
Whatever your opinion of Nancy Pelosi, this
decision I agree with, they were putting insiders
on the panel to investigate what they incited.
It's absolutely crazy.
The Associated Press reporting House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi rejected two Republicans selected
by Kevin McCarthy.
McCarthy said the Republican Party won't participate
in the investigation if Democrats won't accept
the members he appointed.
Pelosi cited the integrity of the probe in
refusing to accept the appointments of Jim
Banks picked by McCarthy to be the top Republican
on the panel or Ohio Congressman Jim Jordan.
The two men are outspoken allies of Trump,
whose supporters laid siege to the Capitol
that day and interrupted the certification
of Joe Biden's when both of them voted to
overturn the election results in the hours
after the siege.
Not a trivial detail.
Democrats have said the investigation will
go on either way.
Pelosi said she spoke to McCarthy and told
him she would be rejecting the two names.
OK, good.
So what do Republicans now?
Do they again frame themselves as the victims?
Let's take a look at a press conference that
Kevin McCarthy did.
And let's listen and then we will discuss.
Speaker 2: We will run our own investigation.
Right.
We have law enforcement, we have military,
we have doctors, we have people from all walks
of life, they want to know the answer.
The American people deserve that.
They don't deserve politics.
They don't deserve destroying the institution.
No committee in Congress will work.
If one person is picking all who can
Speaker 1: surf now, of course, it's not true
that one person is picking all who can surf,
and it's not true that it is a high that it's
exclusively a Democratic commission.
Three of the five people that Kevin McCarthy
selected, Nancy Pelosi has no problem with
Nancy Pelosi has also selected a Republican
in Liz Cheney to be on the committee so that
it would be bipartisan, even with Kevin McCarthy
pulling everybody.
But Liz Cheney is the wrong type of Republican.
And we'll get back to Liz Cheney momentarily.
But the most important thing to remember is
that the initial structure of this investigation
that was proposed months ago was by definition,
bipartisan, and Republicans rejected it.
The initial setup was going to be 10 members.
Democrats choose five.
Republicans choose five.
Every Democratic member would be the chair.
A Republican member would be the vice chair.
And every subpoena sent out to a witness would
have to be signed off on by both the Democratic
chair and the Republican vice chair.
Republicans rejected that entire framework.
And we're going to get to hear why that was
and the revisionist history around that.
Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Mr. Leader, you're complaining
that you don't have a bipartisan opportunity
here to investigate January six, but you stood
in the way of a bipartisan commission made
up of independent members, right?
No.
No Republicans.
Yes, you did.
Your conference voted against that.
At least a majority of your conference voted
against that and it was blocked in the Senate.
Why did you not allow that to go forward?
Listen to this.
What you say you want is a bipartisan investigation
into what happened on January six for the
same politics Pelosi played then the same
time when she used the scope of that.
Remember how long it took on January 13th,
Rodney Davis and myself both requested a 9/11
Commission.
Even those who ran the 9/11 Commission criticized
Nancy Pelosi for what she wanted to do.
We had Officer Evans killed on Good Friday.
She said you couldn't look at that.
If you study the 9/11 Commission, they didn't
study what happened on just September 11th.
They study what built up to it.
But she said, no, you could not do that.
Speaker 1: Now, this is maybe the most deceptive
framing of what happened.
Understand that what Republicans wanted to
do when the commission was initially discussed
months ago, Republicans said, we want to study
the context, but what was the context?
Republicans wanted to study.
Republicans wanted to include in a January
6th commission, the protests during the summer
of twenty twenty over police brutality and
the killing of George Floyd.
That's what they wanted to make the January
6th commission about, which was going to make
it a complete and total distraction.
Republicans wanted to include in that January
6th commission, the killing of Steve I'm sorry,
the shooting of Steve Scalise in 2017.
Why?
Because they wanted to make the entire thing
about here, all these different instances
of people going too far.
But mostly it's Democrats and people on the
left going too far.
Nothing to do whatsoever with the January
six commission.
And the context that Republicans wanted to
include in the January 6th commission was
a defense of the claim that the election was
not really won by Joe Biden.
Why?
Because if Republicans in the January 6th
Commission could make the case that the rioters
were right to be upset about the election
results because it really was stolen by Joe
Biden, it would, in a sense, justify their
violent actions on January 6th.
And Nancy Pelosi rightly said, we're not going
to do that.
That's what Kevin McCarthy is talking about,
that Nancy Pelosi rejected.
It's completely dishonest.
And now I don't know what's going to happen.
McCarthy saying they're just going to do their
own commission.
OK, Liz Cheney, by the way, I don't want to
rehabilitate Liz Cheney's image.
As I've said before, Liz Cheney is a horrible
Republican who voted with Trump like 90 percent
of the time.
She just disagreed on this.
One thing here is Liz Cheney saying actually
the two people Pelosi is not allowing on the
commission, their behavior was disgraceful.
She's right not to do it, not to allow them.
Speaker 3: There are three members that the
minority leader proposed that the speaker
did not object to.
She's objected to two members.
And the rhetoric around this from the minority
leader and from those two members has been
disgraceful.
Speaker 1: So Liz Cheney, because of those
comments being called a Republican in name
only, she's not really a Republican.
How can she say that?
Asked again.
She says, I agree with what Nancy Pelosi decided
to do.
Speaker 2: Do you personally do you personally
urge the speaker to take this step?
Speaker 3: I agree with what the speaker has
done
Speaker 1: and then also asked about the specifics
of why she thinks these two shouldn't be on
the commission.
She said the following.
Speaker 3: At every opportunity, the minority
leader has attempted to prevent the American
people from understanding what happened to.
Block this investigation right today, the
speaker objected to two Republican members,
she accepted three others, she objected to
two, one of whom may well be a material witness
to events.
Speaker 1: This is a key thing.
The Republicans want investigators who are
really more witnesses and participants in
what took place
Speaker 3: and led to that day led to January
six, the other who disqualified himself by
his comments in particular over the last twenty
four hours, demonstrating that he is not taking
this seriously.
Speaker 1: So Liz Cheney is on the same page
as Nancy Pelosi.
Liz Cheney is no great hero.
She's a Republican who agrees with Trump on
just about everything.
But on this issue, she is actually seemingly
doing what she believes is right.
So that's the latest with the commission,
which is just becoming a complete joke of
a situation thanks to Republicans.
Let's now talk a little bit about how Republicans
are reacting in the aftermath of this commission
falling apart from the standpoint of it actually
being something Republicans will participate
in meaningfully.